[Music]  i hope you all had a nice easter for  those of you who celebrate easter  yesterday was easter someone uh  who was uh very connected with that  holiday has asked if he could stop by so  please welcome post easter jesus  [Applause]  so uh how are you jesus  well i'm great now but i did have a  pretty intense weekend  i died  yeah that's that's true yeah uh but i  was reborn on easter so you know what  that means uh you tell me well easter is  now my second birthday so everywhere i  go with my new id i get free drinks  check it out  yeah  anyway i gotta go man i'm playing tennis  with the big guy oh really god no no  buddha  see you around coco are we doing this or  what come on we're doing it we're doing  it let's go  see you man let's do this come on  brother let's go  [Music]  buddha doesn't look like he's playing a  lot of tennis